an unprecedented moment after former
president Trump is indicted the news
igniting a political Firestorm as we get
brand new details on what comes next
Trump calling it a political persecution
as he reportedly is going to face more
than 30 criminal charges over alleged
hush money payments we wait to see the
indictment former president is expected
to be arraigned next Tuesday sources
telling Fox he will have his mug shot
and fingerprints taken but will not be
handcuffed Trump's attorney vowing to
fight back
you know when you stretch the law to get
someone you don't like or as a political
opponent in this case
it's very hard to ever get that law to
come back to its original shape today's
proof that you could actually pick a
Target and then try and find a crime
even a crime that's not a crime because
there is no crime history and I'm
telling you there is no crime I know the
facts I know the law and I really want
to see where this is going to go I don't
know Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg is facing
major backlash for bringing this case in
the first place rag being criticized for
using an untested legal Theory to bring
State charges in a federal case
involving alleged campaign Finance
violations Republicans calling it a
political Ploy and say they're ready to
hold the AG accountable
they're trying to destroy Donald Trump
because they fear him at The Ballot Box
they're trying to drain him dry I think
the Democrats know this has nothing to
do with the law they're sending a
message and it really is a slippery
slope when we start indicting our
political opponents particularly active
candidates for office instead of
cleaning up the streets of New York a
George Soros back D.A is focused on
indicting a former president this is
absolutely a political Witch Hunt
through and through this was a campaign
promised by the D.A he said he would
indict the president he has now done so
all right let's discuss Pete hexath
listen how this plays out if it takes a
year or more judge we'll talk about that
to get to actually a trial if he's the
nominee he's going to be running for
president at the same time being a
criminal defendant in a case in New York
City yeah befitting the Banana Republic
we've become that's happened in other
countries around the world where
political opponents have been under
indictment or facing jail time and
they're running for president because
Elites have decided they're not worthy
of that office or they want to get rid
of them but the people back what they
tried to do and were thwarted in the
process it's barely worth talking about
the merits of this case for ways uh the
judge could talk a lot a lot better than
I could we don't know to be fair we
don't know but we know well it seems to
be about and it comes from a a D.A who's
made his entire career downgrading
felonies to misdemeanors or dismissing
cases for criminals and in this case
desperately reaching for a way to find a
felony against a former president who he
promised as you noted he would go after
as a candidate and he has we're going to
talk about the political Fallout from
here uh that I think is the most
important piece and probably doesn't
work in the democrats favor well judge
I'm looking ahead here so there are a
lot of pre-trial motions in ways that
his defense team will try to get rid of
this before it ever gets to trial but
how do you think the process is going to
go if they get to trial of picking
jurors here in New York and holding a
trial of somebody who probably is going
to be running for president I can't even
get that far because as a D.A and as a
former judge who did this for 32 years
uh this charge is insufficient on its
face if you are charging in the
falsifying of business records the
statute of limitations is run if you are
bootstrapping it with a federal offense
you don't have that jurisdiction to
charge a federal offense so people are
saying this is untested legal Theory
this is not untested this is illegal and
any Judge worth his or her salt will
dismiss this indictment if it alleges
what we suspect uh based upon the
insufficiency of the indictment so
there's a lot of places a lot of of
emotions that will be made before we
even get to the trial I don't think we
should get that far I think one of the
things that is so incredibly important
to realize here is that this is
selective prosecution this is a D.A who
has taken one of the most revered one of
the most time-honored DA's offices in
the nation the Manhattan DA's office and
turned it into a kangaroo DA's office
where they are bringing someone in who
was literally running for president on a
crime that they alleged occurred that
Hillary Clinton could have been charged
with uh five times over based on the
fact that she used campaign funds and
charge them as legal expenses and it
wasn't even her money with the added
addition that she split the nation apart
with the Russian collusion delusion she
split families apart she made Americans
fight with each other but this is simply
a continuation of what happened from the
time the left saw Donald Trump running
and they got that steel dossier and they
use it as a basis for a fisa warrant
that they re-upped continuously through
James Comey and the Department of
Justice that gave us an example and I
called it the antics of a third world
country and now they've come full cycle
so I see this not only as a prosecutor I
see it as a politician someone who's run
for office five times I've run in the
state of New York but as an American
this is the takedown of the American
criminal justice system this is the
takedown of America where the left is
literally taking down our Republic and
turning us into a laughing stock and
finally let me say one thing this is the
only man that our enemies feared Donald
Trump is the only man that our enemies
feared you know Putin went in took
Crimea when Obama was there Putin
invades Ukraine when Biden is there
nobody invaded anywhere when Trump was
there and Americans are eating this
president alive the judges is warmed up
and now ready to go okay you talk about
the rest of the world kind of looking at
where we're at the El Salvadoran
president said this
um it's going to be hard for the U.S to
now lecture us and use arguments about
condemning political persecution so from
the outside looking in Jessica we now
have foreign leaders saying you can't
talk to us about political prosecutions
and Corruption and that kind of thing
because they're going to point the
finger at us and say their impression is
that's what this is
I have nothing against the president of
El Salvador I also know nothing about
them if you have the UK prime minister
who says something like that I'd be a
little bit more interested in having
that conversation
um where it stands right now and your
right chance to continue to caution
everyone on this is that we don't know
what's in the indictment we know that
it's supposed to be 30 plus counts which
I think is not what people expected to
begin with we also know that there has
been months of new testimony since his
people like to hearken back and say well
the doj didn't go with this and the FEC
didn't go with this there should be new
information if there isn't shame on
Alvin Bragg and we'll all be saying that
Tuesday at you know 2 22 because he's
arraigned at 2 15 and I know that the
judge is considering unsealing the
indictment ahead of time so maybe that
you know for your Saturday night if you
don't want to watch the the final four
you can do that but there is a lot of
false information flying around about
what's gone on here I've heard this
isn't a crime it is a crime Donald Trump
was an unindicted co-conspirator and
what happened with Michael Cohen he was
was not prosecuted because he was
President of the United States of
America I went back and I looked at the
fec's report on this The General Counsel
said it explicitly that this was an
illegal campaign contribution so the
choice was not to prosecute not that
something was not done that was
inappropriate and was a crime his own
doj said unindicted co-conspirator he
was individual number one in all of
those papers that came out I'm also
hearing a lot about the George Soros
back D.A here George Soros released a
statement he didn't back Alvin Bragg
he's actually never even talked to Alvin
Bragg and I understand that it's a fun
talking point to say that all the
liberal DA's in the country are funded
by this Boogeyman billionaire but we all
know what happened to George Soros in
2018 when he had a pipe bomb sent to his
house by a crazed about that yes it is
we can make criticism how far are we
going to get off the topic here
I'm sorry the congresswoman who was on
TV said Soros back to eight it is
inaccurate and it has put lives in
danger people should just be everything
puts lives in danger but then when
people die it's like it's not a big deal
right we gotta we get we get a mass
shooting in a in a school and whose
lives are in danger according to the
White House I'm just saying if you want
to go in that direction we can all do
that
I want to ask you though about because
you mentioned James Comey and some
things that went on under his watch
um he tweeted and I think we had the
Tweet it's been a good day Greg
well you know um I would I would like to
speak about just like the the people who
are giddy the in the media and
especially in New York I have a feeling
they've probably never been mugged
because we've been we we're witnessing a
pretty big trade we have a D.A that
chose not to prosecute criminals and
devote almost all of his time chasing
the great white whale or the great
orange whale that is Trump so there was
a trade there and why is that important
it's because you're seeing a major
reframing in the way you should actually
the way I look at this world I don't see
things left or right anymore I see
things as inside and outside you know
there were two people that were targeted
this week you couldn't get more opposite
between Matt taibi and Donald Trump one
a renegade Progressive journalist
another a renegade Republican president
what do they have in common they're both
on the outside so this isn't about the
left going after the right it's about
the elites going after The Outsiders and
if you look at all of the things that we
talk about on the show and the things
that piss you off do you know why
nothing gets done because you're the
outside cider right if you're concerned
about the Border if you're concerned
about crime if you're concerned about
inflation and if you happen to like
Trump you're an outsider inside Elites
have no concerns about anything they
don't live in the border states right
they don't have to worry about crime
they don't have to worry about guns
because they've got private security as
for Trump they hate them they don't care
if he was if he was feared by uh foreign
powers they don't care if he had a good
economy they just don't like him they
kept that this guy's getting prosecuted
because of tweets because they mentally
deranged him this is the first
prosecution based on Trump derangement
syndrome we know that we know this is
political don't pretend that this is
over a you know an unindicted
co-conspiracy so that's garbage lastly
we have to go back and think about what
we miss whenever we see a political
Witch Hunt there are three things that I
remember in my lifetime one let me go
back to covid the first two months of
covid we were doing a trump impeachment
we lost two months I remember it was on
every channel while this weird thing got
out of the Pandora's boxed in China but
we were we were getting our teeth sunk
in in Trump theater then you go back
even further 9 11. what happened before
9 11. another political Witch Hunt this
time it was about a blue dress right we
didn't see Al Qaeda coming because we're
too busy worrying about the President
coming that's a Witch Hunt there are
three witch hunts right now there's 911
there's covid what did we talk about
today what was the big story all of
these techno nerds right from Silicon
Valley saying the most biggest threat in
the world the biggest threat in the
world is AI without proper control
without proper control
that hasn't changed
but it's out of the news that got pushed
out of the news because of this because
we can't get enough of trump
that's on the media so
thank you oh I'm sorry what did I do
it's a family show fantastic
great job it's 10 o'clock somewhere hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else